[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros en 5
minutos con nos acompaña hoy mayerlin
vergara pérez una activista colombiana
de derechos humanos y coordinadora
regional para el caribe de la fundación
renacer una organización no
gubernamental de colombia maya lin
bienvenida y felicitaciones usted ganó
recientemente el premio nansen para los
refugiados por su trabajo durante dos
décadas para erradicar la explotación
sexual de niños niñas y adolescentes y
para contexto de nuestros televidentes
este es un premio que reconoce una labor
excepcional de las personas en favor de
los refugiados en distintos lugares
muchos incluso lo llaman el premio nobel
humanitario
mayerlin le pregunto a su fundación
trabaja en la guajira esta es una de las
regiones más pobres de colombia
fronteriza con venezuela además como
afectó la pandemia esta población
bueno muy buenos días a todos muchísimas
gracias por por el tiempo y el espacio
la pandemia ha afectado profundamente
toda la población sobre todo porque en
lo que tiene que ver con la explotación
sexual comercial de niños niñas
adolescentes se ha cambiado de alguna
manera el escenario es decir del
escenario físico al escenario virtual
hoy día los abusadores los explotadores
sexuales están conectando o contactando
a los niños niñas adolescentes a través
de la internet del entorno digital
es muy importante mayerlin que hablemos
de cómo en este entorno los niños
siempre son más vulnerables por favor
explíquenos este drama este fenómeno que
no debería estar sucediendo en ninguna
parte del mundo
si desafortunadamente los niños y las
niñas tienen acceder a la internet
creo que la internet es una herramienta
maravillosa que creo que lo hemos
comprobado todos que es muy valiosa
sobre todo ahorita en la pandemia lo
hemos vivido aún más sin embargo los
abusadores y los explotadores están
contactando a los niños a través de las
redes sociales con perfiles falsos e
incluso a través de los videojuegos en
línea
entonces las mamás y los papás muchas
veces creen que su hijo o su hija está
seguro porque está en la casa porque
está en el computador en el celular tal
vez haciendo las tareas pero es
necesario que estemos muy alertas porque
hay que ir a la vanguardia también de
los explotadores sexuales y no quedarnos
atrás
mayerlin más allá de usted y de este
reconocimiento que recibe usted cree que
este premio promueve algún cambio porque
todos conocemos la situación y lo que se
necesita es más motivación política
tanto internacional como localmente
ustedes qué opinan
esto es lo que esperamos esperamos
movilizar a los gobiernos movilizar
también a las sociedades porque este es
un problema que no es atendido
únicamente por la por la ong como la
fundación renacer sino que necesitamos
la participación activa de los gobiernos
con la asignación presupuestal con
políticas públicas pero también de la
sociedad que seamos una sociedad más
justa con los niños y con las niñas que
escuchemos a los niños y a las niñas y
que los protejamos y que denunciemos la
explotación sexual y la trata de
personas usted siente mayerlin que el
gobierno colombiano está realmente
interesado en esta problemática o por
ejemplo que le ha dado la espalda a
miles de personas incluyendo los
migrantes venezolanos
yo creo que el gobierno colombiano ha
hecho grandes esfuerzos el instituto
colombiano de bienestar familiar ha sido
nuestro aliado por más de 30 años es
decir de ellos con ellos hemos hecho la
atención de las víctimas el vicente del
viceministerio de turismo también se han
hecho grandes esfuerzos con estrategias
maravillosas como la muralla soy yo
desarrollada en cartagena de indias se
ha fortalecido la legislación ya hoy día
tenemos una legislación más fuerte se
han hecho operativos maravillosos desde
la fiscalía sin embargo este es un
problema de largo aliento en el caso de
los refugiados inmigrantes necesitamos
estar trabajando necesitamos seguir
fortaleciendo la atención de los niños
niñas y adolescentes refugiados
inmigrantes bueno y ya para finalizar
muy rápidamente le quiero pedir un
mensaje de sensibilización para la lucha
de este fenómeno
y nosotros como adultos como sociedad
necesitamos escuchar a los niños y las
niñas la explotación sexual y la trata
de personas tiene rostros y duele en lo
más profundo del ser de cada niño de
cada niña y de cada docente en nuestras
manos en las manos de nosotros como
ciudadanos del común está el prevenir la
explotación sexual y denunciarla porque
esto es un delito es un crimen gracias a
ustedes y que entendamos nada más
importante que proteger a nuestros niños
sigan en france24
[Música]